على هذه الطاوله جمعت نيودلهي وزراء
خارجيه كبار الاقتصاد العالمي لكنها لم
تستطع جمع الاراء في نهايه الاجتماع بل
زاد على كاهلها ثقل المحاوله المستمره
لامساك العصا من المنتصف بين خصوم استغلوا
الضيافه لتعويم خلافاتهم السياسيه
اللقاء الذي ترقبه الجميع بين قطبي العالم
جاء هامشيا ولمجرد تبادل اطراف الحديث
حديث ورغم وقته الموجز حمل الكثير
فواشنطن على لسان وزير خارجيتها دعت لوقف
الحرب العدوانيه في اوكرانيا والعوده الى
الدبلوماسيه لكن وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
استبق ذلك باتهام الغرب بمحاوله فرض اجنده
محادثات على الاجتماع وصفها بالكوميديه
عبر تحميل روسيا مسؤوليه اخفاقاتهم
الاقتصاديه
لن يصدر اعلان مشترك من مجموعه العشرين
والغرب هو المسؤول عن ذلك ان بعض الوفود
الغربيه حولت العمل على اجنده مجموعه
العشرين لامر غير جاد عبر تحميلهم روسيا
مسؤوليه اخفاقاتهم الاقتصاديه قبل ساعات
من الاجتماع كانت الاخبار تتوارد عن
استحاله الخروج ببيان ختامي فشل تكلل في
نهايه اللقاء حيث تصدر الخلاف البنود
الاولى من البيان
الدول العشرون المشاركه وافقت على جميع
بنود البيان الخمسه والعشرين بينما اعترضت
روسيا والصين على بندين رئيسيين منها
البندان ينصان على ثلاث نقاط هي التاكيد
على ان الحرب على اوكرانيا اثرت سلبا على
الاقتصاد العالمي
وادانه الاعمال القتاليه وعدم جواز
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه والتهديد بها وفي
حين ادلى الغرب بدلوه فرسيا رفضت البندين
باعتبار الغرب تجاهل دعوتها لتضمين البيان
الختامي ضروره التحقيق في تفجير نورد
ستريم